thanks for coming to listen to my talk
about post-contextual abandoned
inference this is work that's joined
with the rhonyan antoine
maria and mark
and so to tell you about post-contextual
bandit inference let me first talk tell
you about contextual bandits so that
we're all starting from the same page
contextual bandits are a model for
decision making in unknown environments
where we're learning about the
environment at the same time that we're
making decisions and collecting rewards
and it goes like this for every time
step t equals to one two up to capital t
we're going to encounter an individual
drawn from a stationary distribution of
individuals
the individual is going to be
characterized by some baseline coverts
xt that are available to us at the time
of making a decision and some potential
outcomes unavailable to us which
corresponds to the reward
we would see if we took any one of the m
action options available to us
and so imagine a doctor that's waiting
to see a sequence of patients each
patient is associated with some
variables
like their blood pressure their age etc
and based on this information she wants
to choose the best treatment option one
through m for that individual
uh so that decision a t is going to be a
function pi pi for policy
of the context because we want to make
the best decision in the context
possibly some randomization because that
can come in helpful
and all the historical data so far on
context action and outcome from that
action up to time t and excluding time t
so i'm going to call all of this
h of t minus 1. and this represents all
the data we have so far time t
from which we can learn about this
distribution that's unknown to us
after taking an action we get to see the
reward yt corresponding to the action
that we took we don't get to see any of
the outcomes that we the correspond to
actions that we did not take
and there's banded algorithms that try
to optimize the cumulative sum of
rewards we collect over this horizon
there are banded algorithms that try to
optimize the policy we learn at the very
end
and all of these offer opportunities to
improve on non-adaptive randomized
trials and indeed in a lot of applied
fields whether in development econ or by
statistics where we would usually use
randomized trials to learn about
different treatment options there's been
this push to replace them with bandits
because we can
both improve the outcomes for the trial
participants and or improve the policies
learned at the end of the trial
the problem is that whenever we're
interested in more than just the regret
but actually learning some implemented
trial
then we want to actually conduct the
disconference but bandits break status
conference right at the end of the trial
we still want to make credible
conclusions about the values of
different arms or different policies so
we want to conduct statistical inference
that is construct valid confidence
intervals
but here with bandits we're adaptively
changing the armor locations they're no
longer independent and that's going to
break the asymptotics of the usual
estimators and lead to wrong confidence
intervals
so to illustrate this to you
i'll show you this in a simple example
so here i'm considering just a
two arm contextual bandit where the
conditional expectation of rewards given
context is a linear function and i'm
running a epsilon greedy algorithm where
the epsilon is one over square root t so
slowly decaying flourishing
and i'm looking at capital t of 500 and
here i'm looking at the average regret
over 10 000 replications and we see a
familiar sublinear
curve for the regret
now at the end of the trial we want to
you know learn something we want to make
some inference so maybe we want to
understand
uh what are
the what would be the mean reward
marginally of r plus one
so if this were a randomized trial the
way we would assess that is by looking
at the mean reward among the sample that
received arm plus one so it'll be the
sample mean among arm plus one
individual's reward
now if i actually do this in this
experiment that i'm showing you i get
the following histogram for what i would
get for the sample mean over those ten
thousand replications the true sim the
true marginal mean is actually zero but
the sample means that we see our by
stopword and why is that well when are
we pulling on plus one we're pulling r
plus one where we think it's good so the
outcomes that we see for r plus one are
usually bigger than the marginal mean
right so it's biased upward to fix this
we have to correct for this biased
sampling of rm plus one
and the way we can do that one way you
can do that is using importance sampling
so if we were to use important sampling
or inverse propensity weighting
we would look at the average of the
outcomes among individuals treated with
treatment one
but we would upgrade them by the inverse
probability of their being treated with
treatment one right so here we're
conditioning both on their context and
on the history because
we're in an adaptive setting where this
probability also depends on the history
so it's a condition on both
this actually fixes the bias our
estimates are now unbiased
but at the same time they don't look
very normal they have kind of a sort of
a fat tail over here and they look
somewhat skewed
indeed if we were to try and construct
confidence intervals around this
estimate by adding plus minus two
standard errors well let's design say
for 95 percent
coverage right if we're adding plus
minus two standard errors but that would
only yield us 80 coverage if we wanted
80 coverage we would only get 70
coverage
and it's not that it's always
undercovered then we could always just
expand it is that the coverage is
completely unpredictable this is one
example in another example we might be
over covering for example what if we
tried to improve this by say using the w
robust estimator the dr estimator here
we would be centering by the conditional
expectation and maybe this would improve
things right so the conditional
expectation here is this function f of
both action and
context x which is the conditional
expectation of the potential outcome of
action a given the context is x
and if we take the rpw estimator but
re-center things in terms of the
conditional expectation we arrived at
the doubly robust estimator and here i'm
really giving it the benefit of the
doubt by letting you use the true
conditional expectation not even fitting
it
so the estimator that we get is still
unbiased but still not very normal right
the coverage is very unpredictable and
it's hard for us to construct valid
confidence intervals with uh the
coverage that we're actually designing
them for
so what's the issue well both these
estimators ipw and dr they're both
unbiased and w robust remains unbiased
even if we plug in estimates of f
as long as these estimates are based
only on the history so far h right it's
sort of a cross fitting across time
the problem is that each one of those
terms that we're averaging over has
violently different variances
why because
when we run a bandit we're always
letting exploration diminish slowly
if we're letting the exploration
diminish slowly that means that for
larger t the overlap between the action
that which one i evaluate and the action
that was taken historically is going to
diminish to zero and the variance is
going to grow
as it is going to grow with t
and this sort of average of random
variables with
very different variances is exactly what
breaks uh the conditions of the central
limit theorem or even martingale clt in
this case right because we have things
being drawn adaptively so we have to
think about things as martingales
so the solution i'm going to explore in
this talk is stabilizing this estimator
using re-weighting
specifically i'm going to develop the
contextual adaptive w robust estimator
which proceed as follows first we're
going to sequentially estimate these
outcome models in order to approximate
the dr estimator just as i was alluding
to in the second bullet
then we're going to sequentially
estimate the conditional variance of
each one of these terms in the dr
estimator
conditioned on the history
okay and then we're going to rewrite
each term by the inverse of the
estimated conditional standard deviation
and we're going to show that this is
going to guarantee us asymptotic
normality once we have asymptotic
normality constructing confidence
intervals is really easy just plus minus
two standard errors and then i'm going
to show you on an experiment using 57
different data sets that this actually
gives us the inference we want whereas
a lot of standard estimators are going
to give us wrong confidence intervals
so
first i just want to note that this idea
of stabilizing in order to fix clt uh
this builds on uh some past successes
notably ludkin and fandullon they use
stabilization in a completely different
setting where data's iid in order to do
inference and more recently haddad all
used stabilization in order to do
inference in a multi-armed bandit trial
right so they were looking in a
non-contextual bandit problem and
essentially what we're doing here is
extending uh their idea to the
contextual setting there are some key
challenges to this extension
one is that haddad their weights their
civilization weights were actually known
here we have to stabilize using
estimated weights and we have to make
sure that that stabilization still works
we also have to actually estimate these
weights and that's
a hard problem by itself
in order to do so we also have to learn
contextual aqua models from adapted data
so those are all key challenges that are
sort of unique to this extension to
contextual problems
there's also some other related work
that's trying to do
to deal with adaptively collected data
howard at all
constructs finite simple concentration
bounds in order to construct these
confidence intervals but because they're
based on concentration balance they're
going to be
far too conservative
in particular they're not going to be
calibrated so if we want
95 percent coverage we will always way
over cover
more recently cato
looked at doing inference that's
calibrated
but they do not allow the exploration to
vanish towards zero and correspondingly
the method is
is quite simpler
so
first let me define the s demand on
which we will uh run
inference so before i just mention the
marginal mean reward of an arm but we
can do something that's much more
general look at an estimate psi naught
given by any weighted average of the
potential outcomes okay so the weights
are going to be given by this reference
g star which is a function of action and
context for example if we wanted to look
at the average treatment effect or the
ate we would look at g star equal to one
if the action is you know maybe action
two and minus one for some other action
and then we're looking at the average
treatment effect between these two
actions or we can think about evaluating
some counterfactual policy g star and
then g star is just the probability of
taking an action in a given context
and the way we're going to estimate this
estimate is by taking the dr estimator
and stabilizing it so first we have to
make some definitions to construct the
dr estimator first we define gt to be
the policy that the bandit used at time
t essentially it's the
distribution assigned to action at time
t given any one context
of course because our
policies are dependent on historical
data they're essentially constructed
adaptively
this gt is a random function that's
measurable with respect to the history
this is in contrast to the independent
setting or id setting where usually we
think about a longing policy that's just
some fixed policy of a and x
here it's going to be random and
measurable respect to the historical
data
then the estimator is going to be
constructed as follows we're going to
construct the dr estimator by taking the
so-called dr influence function which is
essentially a generalization of
the dr estimator we had before now
looking at generalized
general weighted estimates and we're
going to take its sample mean
by plugging in some estimate for the
conditional
mean of the rewards which is some
estimate that's based only on the data
so far whenever we're looking at the t
tf term
and then we're going to reweight it
using these sigmas
and these sigmas are also something
that's measurable with respect to the
studio so far and which are these
segments proxies well these sigmas are
trying to get at the true conditional
standard deviation of the dr influence
function so if we look at the dr
influence function at time t what we
care about is its conditional standard
deviation given the history
then we can show
that if we have what we call a
non-trivial efficiency bound so
essentially the variance of the dr
influence term
should be positive
as it usually should be
and if we estimate these true
conditional standard deviations
consistently and if our exploration
is diminishing only very slowly towards
zero in the sense that it's not it's
diminishing slower than one over t
then we can show that our estimator is
asymptotically normal
but one of the most crucial steps here
is actually coming up with these
conditional standard deviation
estimators that are consistent
so that is where a lot of the work lies
and one of the key challenges in
constructing this estimator is that
we're trying to estimate the conditional
variance of a random variable that we
only observe once
so the trick that we use is to use a
sort of meta-important sampling to
important sampling the dr estimator
itself in order to estimate the
conditional variance using the data we
have so far so unfortunately i don't
have too much time to talk about the
details of this
but the punchline is that
we are able to construct
a standard deviation estimator that is
consistent in the sense desired under
some appropriate conditions
and then the question is well how does
this actually play out in practice so to
study this we considered 57 different
classification data sets given from the
openml
cc18
corpus and we turned each one
essentially into contextual banded
instance by giving a reward for correct
classification and then we ran through
these data sets many many times
with different algorithms
and these data sets have different sizes
different number of classes and
different amounts of features
and then the punch line is that overall
our estimator cutter when we design it
to have 95 coverage the coverage it gets
which is shown in the y-axis in each one
of these plots is about 95 as desired
whereas the coverage of alternative
estimators shown in the x-axis of these
plots
is varying all over the place right so
if we want 95 coverage actually ipw plus
minus two standard errors gives us
anywhere between 25 and 75 coverage and
this behavior is consistent among
different settings that we consist that
we consider of course sometimes things
do break especially when we have uh
small amounts of data or very extreme
propensities
so
i'll end here and just recap uh the
takeaway messages which is that
bandit algorithms offer a an opportunity
for a lot of improvements over
non-adaptive experimentation
and therefore they're quite appealing in
a lot of applied fields but in the same
fields we also want to run inference at
the end we don't just care about
collecting very little regret and
collecting a lot of reward we also want
to learn something at the end so to
learn something at the end would mean to
conduct inference to support credible
conclusions the problem is that these
banded algorithms they break statistical
inference
so that's the challenge that we tackled
today and to solve it i presented this
estimator they came up with the cutter
estimator which is the first
asymptotically normal estimator under
contextual adaptive data collection
right so whenever we're actually running
contextual bandits and not
non-contextual bandits
and
what this does is allow us to do valid
statistical inference and guarantee
correct coverage
um so i'll end here
and just thank you again for coming to
my talk thanks
you